as Holy Week is on the Western
Christians and as it is coming closer
for Eastern Christians and also in the
wake of the Nakhla Dom fire I thought
that we might want to make a video on
beauty and meaning and so I want to talk
about the different icons which appear
during the Holy Week in the Orthodox
tradition and how they are interrelated
and finally bring about the ultimate
meaning of Easter of pasca and the
resurrection
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world so this week has been a
rather difficult week with the fire of
new tadam
I have to admit that I was surprised to
what extent it affected me you know I on
the day of the fire I just sat there in
front of my computer and for some reason
I just couldn't stop crying for a few
hours and I kept trying to reason myself
and tell myself you know nobody died
there are much bigger tragedies in the
world and of course that's true there
are most more way more horrible
tragedies but I thought that because
this fire represented something rather
profound about the state of Western
civilization the state of Christianity
in Europe and also the growing a growing
mirror of that in North America it
seemed that watching the church burn
really hit a nail and manifested in me
and in so many people that I saw around
a sense of dread about what is happening
in Europe and what is happening to
Christianity and so I think that despite
that it also encouraged me in my own
work and in my own purpose which is to
show the beauty of our traditions to
show the beauty of Christianity the
beauty of Christ and in art and
architecture in symbolism and so I
figured what better thing to do than to
actually talk about some of that beauty
and some of that meaning and hopefully
to wake up a few people to what it is
we're losing as Christianity is on the
wane and so during Holy Week in the
Orthodox tradition there are a series of
icons which appear and what's
interesting about these icons is of
course they take us down the
story of Holy Week towards the
crucifixion and the resurrection but
they also exemplifies something that
I've been telling you about for quite a
while now which is the interrelated
aspect of symbolism how symbolism is
really a pattern and so because it is a
pattern there are residences which
appear you could say it this way that
the icons talk to each other they call
upon each other and what that does is it
creates a synth and symphonic effect a
symphony of imagery which all you know
cross over into each other and create
this interconnected web of meanings and
so when we look at the icons of Holy
Week we can see that happen quite
beautifully and it can also help us to
understand certain elements of certain
icons not by analyzing the icons on
their own looking at what's in the icon
but at looking at how those icons relate
to other icons in the same cycle into
the cycle of Holy Week and it can help
us to see why certain details are
sometimes put into those images and so
as we start of course Holy Week we
should start at the entry into Jerusalem
Palm Sunday that icon represents Christ
entering into Jerusalem as a kingly
figure sitting on an ass or a cult and
coming into the city as young children
cut palmed up in the trees and people
take off their vestments and put them at
the feet of Christ as Christ is entering
onto his ass and as we look at this
image what it does is it also opens up
this vision that we have in in the cycle
of Holy Week which is a vision of
extremes and it opens up this vision of
extremes the the vision of extremes is
to help us see the profound paradox but
also the intuitively right aspect of
Christ as being both the highest joining
with the lowest and so being the the
Incarnate logos
the the manifestation of the source the
origin of all the world and then
bringing that logos down to the bottom
of the world and showing how it connects
how it even unites with the lowest of
the low and so that is what we see in a
Holy Week especially during a certain
service I forget what it's called in
English but there's a service towards
the end of a Holy Week which is a
service of complaints a service of
mourning where that is what we cite in
this service of mourning in the service
of lamentation we get sentences which
compare the extremes for example the the
one which I find the most touching is as
Christ is being put down into the grave
we hear Oh strange wonder new to man he
who granted me the breath of life is
carried lifeless into Joe in Joseph's
hands to burial another example he who
holds the earth in the hollow of his
hand is held fast by the earth put to
death according to the flesh he delivers
the dead from the grasping hand of hell
and so it is this this this raising up
and then bringing down and showing how
both of those at the same time this
total reality of of the highest joining
with the lowest is what frees us from
the low the the curse of the lowest is
what frees us from the curse of death
another example
he appears now as a corpse without form
or comeliness he who has made beautiful
the nature of all things and so here is
this extreme so as we start already as
we start the the procession of Holy Week
as we start the story of Holy Week we
start with the high and so here comes
Christ into Jerusalem and everybody is
acclaiming him as the new king and and
he's entering into what seems to be a
honorable place an interesting aspect of
the of the icon of the entry into
Jerusalem is that a later tradition
somewhere
around the 14th century we think a
detail was added to some of those icons
which which held and it was perpetuated
and in this this detail what we see is
we see a two young children of course
these children that are taking the palms
out of the trees two young children on
sitting on the ground in the foreground
and one of them has a thorn in their
foot and the other child is trying to
help that one to remove the thorn from
their foot and so you would think why
why would such a detail be added to an
image of the entry into Jerusalem seems
like a very strange thing to add and the
reason seems to be related to this
pattern of icons because the very next
icon that we will see in the story of
Holy Week is an icon called the
bridegroom the icon of the bridegroom is
of course in the Latin tradition called
a che homo here is the man and we see
Christ as a king he is wearing he has a
reed he's holding his staff he's wearing
a purple vestment and he also is wearing
a crown but of course this crown is the
crown of thorns and in this image once
again we have the joining of the two
extremes the an exalted imagery of a
king which is then taken down to the
lowest of a man who is being tortured
and mocked and so they are mocking him
as the king it's a mirror image of the
day of the the icon we saw just the day
before which is the praising of him as
the king and so now they're mocking him
as a false King or as a has an imaginary
King and they're torturing him and
putting on his head the crown of thorns
now of course I've talked about this
before the crown of thorns is in my
opinion one of the most powerful symbols
of Christianity because it is taking the
curse of death the curse that God put on
Adam and Eve one of those curses was
that the world was going to produce
thorns the thorns are the hostility of
the world
are also an image of death itself
because they are these pointy
protrusions of the of the plant to
protect themselves from a hostile world
and but there are there like nails or
horns of an animal they're dead
themselves they're not they're not
living things they're like weapons to
protect ourselves from death I've talked
about this quite a few times before this
notion of a layer of death to protect us
from death and so now Christ takes this
layer of thorns this curse of the fall
and flips it over and brings it up into
a glory and that of course is the crown
of thorns now that can help you to
understand why as we see Christ entering
into Jerusalem we already see these two
children who are at the bottom of the
icon dealing trying to deal with the
thorns because it is it's to show us
that this is all part of the same
pattern this high cannot exist without
this low it's our ready to show the high
end the low together even in the very
icon in the next icon we show we show
the lowness but we also hint at the
Highness by the image of the the crown
and the the icon is called the
bridegroom and you would think once
again how very strange that an icon of
Christ you know tortured this.h a homo
image would be called the bridegroom and
it's because the very next things think
we celebrate that we commemorate in Holy
Week is the parable of the wise and
foolish virgins in the parable of the
wise and foolish virgins there are wise
virgins who are ready to receive the
bridegroom and foolish virgins who are
not ready to receive the bridegroom and
the foolish virgins are cut out whereas
the wise virgins are held inside the
house to receive the bridegroom who is
coming for the wedding feast and so it
is already in a certain manner an image
of the Last Judgement but also an image
of us preparing ourselves for our groom
preparing ourselves as the church
preparing our souls to receive the
divine logos
receive our our divine groom in the
figure of of Christ but who is this
divine groom we saw it it is this
tortured man and so once again this
notion of the husband of the the Feast
of the bridegroom of the high you know
of the the glorious husband who comes to
take his bride to take our soul to join
with our soul in this in the sexual
symbolism is is also the extremes are
shown because this bridegroom is
manifested as as the tortured christ in
the hea home image okay and so you see
what like I said these extremes back and
forth coming coming in and out in the
story of Holy Week now as we move
forward the next image that we celebrate
on holy Wednesday is the icon of the
washing of the disciples feet now in the
icon of the washing of the feet once
again we are playing with all the
different elements that we've seen
before in the image of the entry into
Jerusalem Christ comes in triumphant
he's sitting on on the ass and everybody
is taking their vestments off and
putting them at the feet of Christ as he
enters into the town so Christ comes in
and then we see him on holy Wednesday in
the room with the disciples and now he
is removing his vestment in order to
wash the feet of his disciples and so
the contrast is amazing and you can and
in the icon of the washing of the feet
usually in icons we don't we often don't
show a lot of extreme emotions things
are kind of straightened out and and
sobered up you could say so to not fall
into sentimentality but in this icon
there is the pose of Saint Peter which
is very remarkable and it is this pose
of confusion to it to know that here is
the same person who is acclaimed as the
the King of the Jews as
the messiah who is now coming down to
the bottom and acting as a servant to
wash his disciples feet so then we move
on to the next icon which is the icon of
the mystical supper now here again we
have to understand that this is
happening on the same evening as the
washing of the feet and now Christ takes
up again his position as the head of the
table as the head of the family as the
one who is giving the food to the
disciples who is giving his body who is
giving his blood and so he is giving his
body and his blood in a manner of
authority where he is he is telling the
disciples here is how it's going to be
I'm giving you my bread in my body for
you to commune in and he's doing it in a
position of authority but of course we
know we know what's coming we know that
that actual giving of the body and blood
of Christ will happen on the cross where
Christ will be treated as a criminal
will be will be treated as the lowest of
the low will be stripped naked and
beaten and put on this cross until once
again the extremes are being seen in
that very scene and you also have to
understand that you can imagine
that Christ washes the disciples feet
and when he washed the disciples feet
although it is not said explicitly in
the text it is implied that all the the
apostles were there and that includes
Judas until Christ washed Judas his feet
and then during the the mystical supper
during the during that evening he then
tells Judas to go and do what he has to
do and he also does it you know in
giving him a piece of bread or sometimes
it's also Judas who reaches and takes
the piece of bread so but you can see
like I said the extremes who just repeat
themselves over and over so then of
course we then come to Holy Thursday we
come to the actual crucifixion of Christ
Holy Thursday in the evening which is
already Holy Friday that's another
complicated issue
it's fine you can understand that we now
come to the crucifixion and so now we
see where all of this has led to where
all of this has come to which is this
image which is the image in which all is
accomplished and it is the image of
Christ at the cross and so in this image
of Christ we see all the extremes coming
together and so once again the extreme
of him being tortured like a criminal
on a strip naked and tortured publicly
on this cross but then just like when he
was beaten he had on his head the crown
of thorns now again we put on his head
or above his head we put a sign which
says Jesus Jesus of Nazareth King of the
Jews and in the Orthodox tradition
iconographic traditions often people
will write Jesus Christ King of glory or
just the King of glory and so this idea
to try to make it this image into a
cosmic image to make it to say that yes
of course
Christ is the king of the Jews but
what's happening here at the crucifixion
is a cosmic event and he is becoming in
this moment of extremes which are
smashing together in one moment these
the highest and the lowest coming
together in this moment he is resolving
all the opposites and it is a cosmic
event of course the cosmic event is
shown not only with Christ on the cross
but it is also shown by images of the
Sun and the moon which appear on the
icon of the crucifixion we often see
sometimes they're made their figurative
sometimes it's a it's a two characters
usually one blue one red and they're
hiding themselves from the event
sometimes they're more abstract just
shapes of the Sun and the moon and sadly
for people for some strange insane
reason have been asking me about this
image and thinking that it is UFOs which
are represented in this in this instance
it is not UFOs it is the Sun in the moon
this is just a universal crease
image which has been there forever and
so don't give up with the conspiracy
theories okay and so here we have Christ
extending his hands out and the Sun and
the moon are there inside and so as he
extends his hands out and and contains
let's say all the opposites he's also
containing all of the cosmos with in
that moment he is spreading his hands
out to stretch out to the ends of the
world is a way to understand it and so
being stretched out on the cross is a
moment of death it's a moment of torture
but it is also a moment where he's
filling up the hierarchy both the
vertical and the horizontal hierarchy
filling it up completely with the divine
logos and that of course again is in
this this paradox of reality you know
that we're seeing on the cross now from
that moment of the crucifixion what we
start to see is there's a few more icons
which come after the crucifixion and
many of those icons are already
contained within the image of the
crucifixion so let me explain what I
mean at the bottom of the cross you see
there is a cave or the earth is
splitting and in that cave you see a
skull that skull is the skull of Adam it
is the skull of man it is dead man it is
the man who has been taken by the curse
of death and you see Christ's blood
which is pouring down on his on his legs
on the cross and which is often you see
it you don't always see the blood but in
some way did you see the blood is
pouring down onto the skull of Adam and
so this of course has all to do with the
fact that Christ the the place where
Christ was crucified is called Golgotha
which is the place of the skull and then
in the tradition it becomes a strange
compression of many things where the
Golgotha the place of the skull is
recognized in some traditions to be the
place of burial where
was buried in other traditions it comes
to be the place of paradise itself you
know the place of the Tree of Life all
of this kind of comes together where the
cross becomes the tree of life but also
becomes the place where Adam died the
two extremes smashed together we end
Christ enters into paradise on that in
that moment but also goes to the end of
death at the same time those two things
are happening at once and the image of
the blood coming on to the skull of Adam
is showing us something which is
happening in in another icon which is
the icon of the resurrection or the icon
of the Anastasis the icon of the
resurrection is actually not an image of
the resurrection proper it is an image
of what we call the descent into Hades
and so as Christ descends into death you
see him now entering this cave it is the
very cave that you saw under the cross
and what's happening there under the
cross is now shown explicitly you know
what is happening on the cross when
Christ is dying and we see Christ going
down into death and there he goes and he
grabs Adam and he grabs Eve he grabs the
first people to to show us that it's all
of us right it's all men who are you
know in that let's say in Adams womb we
could say the way that that the Bible
talks about being in the womb of Abraham
in the and not the womb sorry the bosom
of Abraham so in the bosom of Adam we
are all contained in the bosom of Adam
and so Christ is pulling out Adam and
Eve out of death and we see in the image
the the the breaking of the doors of
hell you see those doors underneath
Christ's feet you see also usually
there's Hades who's down there in the
dark place who is chained and held
sometimes this Hades and the devil as
well and Satan who are both chained up
down at the bottom of Hell and then you
also see bits and pieces of iron and so
these bits and pieces of iron are
actually let's say pieces of the dough
that is pieces of the locks and pieces
of the of the hinges of the door of hell
and you might think well that's a very
strange kind of random thing to put
there but it's important because what it
shows is that that this dark space of
death is this base we talk about it in
the space of chaos it's the space where
things stop having meaning and so so
having these bits and pieces of iron
that are broken and have no recognisable
are not recognizable anymore or are
barely recognizable or are broken or are
fragmentary this is all related to the
symbolism of death itself which is this
fragmentation you know this breaking
apart of meaning the decomposition all
of that is shown by by you know in the
image of showing these bits and pieces
of doors and locks and pins that are
flying out you know from this flying out
from this this moment of the
resurrection and so so what like I said
what's important to understand is that
this image is already there in the image
of the crucifixion when you look at the
image of the crucifixion what you see
down at the bottom of the Cross is
already the image of the Anastasis it's
as if the image of the anastacio is
inside the crucifixion and then we're
kind of we're kind of going in and
opening it up so that we see what's
behind the crucifixion what's behind the
crucifixion is this glorious moment
where Christ is pulling Adam and Eve out
of the out of death and so the other the
other image also of Holy Saturday which
is the older image actually of the
resurrection is not once again the image
of the resurrection
interestingly enough in Orthodox
iconography tradition ancient Orthodox
iconography people did not show the
actual resurrection because it's not
described in the Bible and so we don't
have an image of you know Christ coming
out of his you know coming out of his
grave what we have is this imagistic
image of Christ in death saving Adam and
Eve from from Hades and then we also
have this other image which
is the angel who is showing the women
who come to the tomb of Christ he is
showing the women the empty tomb and if
you look at the empty tomb you see a lot
of the things that I talked about first
of all you see this cave this this
opening in the ground which is the same
opening that we had in this the the icon
of the Anastasis and is the same opening
that we had in the image of the
crucifixion but it's also an other
opening it's also the same opening that
we had in the icon of the birth of
Christ if you look at the icon of the
birth of Christ you see Christ lying in
a manger wrapped in swaddling clothes
and the way that we represent the manger
is very similar to the manner in which
we then represent the tomb of Christ and
now here are these same swaddling
clothes here are these here this linen
which was Christ was wrapped in and it
is empty and so it connects us the end
to the beginning and it also shows us
that this was the purpose from the start
that the entering of Christ in the
entering of the logos into creation was
already a a dying you would say it was
already a dying but at the same time
like I said a full of filling up death
with light filling up death with life
those two those two contradictions at
the same time and so as you can see the
images which are chosen for Holy Week
there's also of course the image of some
of them that I didn't show which are the
the taking down of Christ on the cross
and also the burial of Christ where we
see Christ laying down on on the tomb
and that image is extremely important as
well because it shows us that the
relationship as Christ is shown lying
down this is a little more complicated
for people to understand but in
iconography and in imagery to show
someone lying down is not random it is
meaningful to show someone lying down is
to show them dead or asleep because
that's when you lie down and so to have
have him lying down is also pointing to
this mystery where on the cross you saw
him up standing
and filling up the hierarchy now lying
down and coming down into death it also
connects the the image of Christ laying
down sleeping dead to the image of the
of what's happening at the same time
secretly inside so you see him lying
down on the on the grave but then in the
Anastasis image you see him standing up
glorious and often he's holding his
cross in his hand in the image of the
resurrection to say here's the tool of
my of my torture in my death and now it
has become for me a banner of victory a
weapon of victory and took he holds his
his cross in his hands like he would
hold a banner where he would hold a
sword or something like that to show
these extremes this contrast coming
together and so it's important to
understand of course when I talk about
these extremes is not just the extremes
because Christianity is obviously not a
religion of dualism is not a religion of
duality I mean it is in a certain manner
a religion of duality but a duality
which comes to be United United without
confusion and so does not become joining
together the opposites does not become a
kind of of chaotic mush you know of
nonsense but rather it is a you perfect
union of opposites a perfect union of
diversity into unity which preserves the
multiplicity and preserves even the
duality we say that Christ is both
perfectly God and perfectly man united
you know
without mixture and perfect distinction
between his two natures it's like it's
so strange to two that Christians
insisted so much on those definitions
and it is really this is really the
secret and you can see it in the story
of Holy Week where it is the fact that
those two extremes are two are there and
are brought together without negating
the extremes but but that that's how the
world exists you know and this is really
the mystery of how the world exists
which is that unity and duality unity
and multiplicity need to coexist I need
to exist in a manner which does not
dissolve one or the other and so I hope
this little explication of the icons of
Holy Week have been helpful for those of
you who are celebrating are in Holy Week
this week and are moving towards Easter
this Sun this Saturday this Sunday I
want to I wish you a blessed Easter and
I wish you all the best and for those of
us who are going to celebrate next week
as well I wish you a you know a fruitful
Holy Week and hopefully we can move
beyond you know the the news and beyond
all the things that are pulling us apart
I myself during this period of Lent has
I found this period of Lent extremely
difficult feel like I've been on a
roller coaster of being pulled apart and
so I ask I ask God that this holy week I
can find a find the the peace that he
that he brings us at pasca and so thanks
again everybody and I will see you soon
[Music]